hey 42 here the world is full of
mysteries
what if anything is hidden inside area
51
why did mcdonald's choose a terrifying
psycho clown as a mascot
and just what the hell were they
thinking when they made the final series
of game of thrones the subject of
today's video is an enigma so perplexing
that people have been hard at work
trying to solve it for hundreds of years
like all the best mysteries it's a
classic tale of buried treasure and
booby traps but one that comes with an
intriguing plot twist
when it comes to finding hidden
treasures the hard part is usually
figuring out where to dig in the first
place
but in this case we know exactly where
the treasure trove is buried the problem
is nobody can figure out how the hell to
get it out of the ground
[Music]
hundreds perhaps thousands of people
have tried over the years including
randomly enough the likes of franklin d
roosevelt errol flynn and john wayne
a handful have even died in the process
but
to this day the treasure continues to
stubbornly refuse to come out of the
ground
as for why
well that's going to take a bit of
explaining so
make yourself comfortable because this
is the truly bizarre tale of the lost
treasure of oak island quite possibly
the longest running active treasure hunt
on earth
our story begins over 200 years ago in
1795
with a man named daniel mcginnis he was
scouring a little speck of land called
oak island just off the nova scotian
coast
in search of a good spot to build a farm
whether or not he found a nice fertile
patch of land on which to plant some
crops is unknown but what he did find
was an odd circular depression on the
ground
mcginnis had been brought up on stories
of buried treasure and in perhaps the
most famous of those tales a notorious
pirate by the name of captain kidd who
was said to have buried two million
pounds worth of loot on an island
somewhere to the east of boston
considering oak islands somewhere to the
east of boston location and the
suspicious nature of the depression
mcginnis had found he figured it was
probably a good time to go get some
shovels
returning the following day with a
couple of friends mcginnis began to dig
the ground was surprisingly soft but
after about three meters the men struck
something hard
not a treasure chest but a plank of
solid oak it didn't seem like much of a
find at first but as the men continued
to dig
they came across another plank
then another they also began to notice
evidence of old pick and shovel marks
lining the walls of their fast-growing
hole
the implication
was clear mcginnis and his friends were
excavating a deep pit
that person's unknown had dug and filled
in
long ago
oak island is small and relatively
remote
and there was quite literally no reason
whatsoever for anybody to dig a really
big hole
unless they wanted to hide something
very valuable
at the bottom of it
the hunt for captain kidd's lost
treasure was well and truly on
but mcginnis and his friends never got
the chance to find out just how many
boats and hoes you can buy for one
buried treasure because after digging a
good 10 meters or so straight down
that's about the height of a three-story
building there was still no sign of the
loot
without the time tools or manpower to
dig any deeper
the great big hole in the ground which
is today known as the money pit
was abandoned
not that it stayed that way for long
word got out that pirate gold had been
located on oak island and soon enough a
trickle of treasure hunters that would
one day become a flood began to descend
on the south coast of nova scotia
in 1802 three years after daniel
mcginnis's initial discovery a group of
30 men from a nearby settlement called
onslow turned up armed to the teeth with
shovels and pickaxes
the onslow group soon sank the money pit
significantly deeper into the ground
than mcginnis and his friends had
managed excavating all the way down to
about 27 metres
they made a few interesting discoveries
too
just like mcginnis they uncovered wooden
platforms at regular three meter
intervals but
they also found a large stone inscribed
with a cipher that would eventually be
decoded to reveal a tantalizing message
ten feet below
are two million pounds buried
but just when it seemed like captain
kidd's treasure was about to be
reclaimed disaster struck
returning to the money pit one morning
the onslow group found it swimming in 18
meters of water
it was a weird development to say the
least there'd be no rain during the
night and with the technology available
at the time the mine shaft that was
apparently just meters away from two
million pounds worth of genuine buried
treasure
became essentially unusable
undeterred the men from onslow dug a
parallel shaft next to the money pit
with the intention of coming at the
treasure from the side
but by this point funding was running
out and when the second shaft flooded
too
the group were forced to give up and go
home
it was almost 50 years before a company
from the town of truro made the next
serious attempt to dig up captain kidd's
treasure horde
arriving in 1849 the truro company
re-excavated both pits that had been dug
by the onslow group
but once again the whole soon filled up
with water
and here's where things start to get a
bit weird because the men of the truro
company noticed something the onslow
group hadn't the water in the pits was
slightly salty
and it seemed to rise and fall with the
tide and that meant that the money pit
which was located a good 40 meters from
the nearest shoreline
was somehow flooding with sea water
after conducting a quick search of the
island's beaches the group discovered
the entrance to a narrow channel that
disappeared underground in the general
direction of the money pit
whenever the tide was at its highest the
channel would fill with water flooding
the pit
in other words the treasure pit was
booby-trapped
on the one hand
this was incredibly bad news
the flood system was clearly a
sophisticated piece of engineering and
overcoming its defenses was going to be
a huge challenge
but there was a flip side to this
particular coin if captain kidd had gone
to such lengths to prevent anyone from
reaching the bottom of his pit
he must have buried something of
unimaginable value down there
the truro treasure hunters did
everything in their power to try and
reach the trapped treasure
they dug multiple shafts deep into the
ground around the money pit each of
which came at the presumed location of
the loot from a different direction
but
ultimately it was all in vain
no matter where they dug their
excavations were played with flooding
and unexpected collapses and eventually
the toro company were forced to abandon
the island for
good that was just over 170 years ago
and
in the time since
innumerable treasure hunters have washed
up on the shores of oak island with
designs on the riches at the bottom of
the money bit
some have focused their efforts on
trying to circumvent the flood tunnel
booby traps
others have tried digging shafts
elsewhere on the island at least six
people have lost their lives in the
process
sparking faintly ridiculous rumors of a
curse
treasure hunting technology has improved
dramatically since daniel mcginnis's day
in the 1860s the first steam pumps
arrived
but they didn't have the power to keep
up with the relentless incursion of
flood water
in 1909 a company of treasure hunters
called the old gold salvage group
brought boring equipment and divers to
the money pit
but like those before them
they left oak island empty-handed
randomly enough an up-and-coming lawyer
by the name of franklin delano roosevelt
was amongst the members of the old gold
salvage group
despite the group's failure it's said
that roosevelt maintained an interest in
the goings-on on the island for the rest
of his life and had even planned a visit
in 1939 but was forced to cancel when
the second world war broke out
there have been far too many expeditions
to oak island to list them all in this
video but fdr wasn't the only household
name to get himself tangled up in the
mystery
legendary actors errol flynn and john
wayne
both provided financial backing to
various expeditions
and it's rumored that a pair of treasure
hunters who arrived on oak island in the
1930s were ordered to report their
findings directly to the king of england
george vi
these days the hunt for treasure is led
by brothers rick and marty laguna
who are documenting their efforts for a
tv series on the history channel
now the fact that the show is currently
nine series deep probably tells you all
you need to know about how well things
are going
admittedly the brothers have dug plenty
of interesting knick-knacks up out of
the ground
old coins military paraphernalia
maritime trinkets even some jewelry but
as yet they failed to hit captain kids
jackpot
to be honest at this point it's all
starting to get a bit awkward
and with every treasureless year that
passes
it's getting harder and harder to ignore
a certain nagging question what if there
was never any treasure on oak island in
the first place
considering just how many people have
spent their time and money searching for
captain kids treasure it's easy to
assume that we must know for sure that
there's something down there but in
reality
that isn't really the case
for starters the whole story is
essentially nothing more than a legend
daniel mcginnis supposedly stumbled
across the money pit around 1795
but the first documented account of
those events didn't show up until 1857
and key details of the story differ
depending on who you talk to and which
source you read
there's also no evidence beyond word of
mouth stories that captain kidd ever
buried any treasure on oak island in the
first place
even more alarmingly it turns out the
whole idea that pirates routinely buried
their treasure
is actually largely a myth
a plot device invented by the likes of
robert louis stevenson
as a framework around which to build
swashbuckling piratey adventures
in fact you might be surprised to learn
that almost everything you think you
know about pirates is probably wrong
the modern image of the stereotypical
pirate has been hugely influenced by
novels like treasure island
where historical accuracy took a back
seat in favour of an exciting plot
for example no pirate in history
is ever known to have kept a parrot as a
pet
peg legs though not unheard of are
thought to have been fairly rare amongst
pirates
and there's no evidence that walking the
plank was ever a common piratey
punishment
even the iconic pirate accent we all
know and well
hate
is completely false
pirates talk that way in every film
you've ever seen
solely thanks to british actor robert
newton who played long john silver in
disney's 1950 version of treasure island
having grown up in dorset in england
newton had a thick west country accent
he just made the most of it for the role
and yeah the rest is history ahoy me
hearties
okay so if pirates didn't actually bury
their treasure in the first place then
presumably that means the odds of there
being pirate treasure on oak island
are essentially zero right
actually not exactly you see it turns
out that in all of recorded history
there is precisely
one
well documented case of a pirate burying
treasure and it just so happens that the
pirate who did the burying on that
occasion was none other than captain
william kidd
now admittedly the treasure in question
was buried a good 500 miles south west
of oak island on gardiner island
and it was only actually in the ground
for less than a year before it was dug
off in newton's evidence against kid in
the trial for which he was eventually
hanged but still the fact that captain
kidd definitely did bury treasure
somewhere
means we can't rule out the possibility
that he might have done so on oak island
too
but
here's a question for you
why
why on earth would he go to the trouble
of digging a 30 meter booby-trapped hole
to put treasure in if he wanted to keep
something valuable safe for later
wouldn't just a few meters have done the
trick
these days we have jcbs and ground
penetrating radar
and we still aren't able to find the
treasure
so there's no chance the technology of
kids day would have been able to get to
it
meaning whatever he buried
was basically gone for good and if that
was his intention all along
why didn't he just chuck it into the
bottomless depths of the ocean and sail
off into the sunset like the badass
pirate he was
[Music]
in 1995 the woods hole oceanographic
institution
conducted a two-week long scientific
survey of oak island in an attempt to
shed some light on the existence or lack
thereof of any buried treasure what they
found wasn't exactly encouraging
not only was there no evidence of any
swag
the team also concluded that the famous
flooding of the money pit
wasn't caused by an ingenious 200 year
old booby trap at all
but by natural processes relating to the
island's geology
speaking of geology it turns out that
the land not far from oak island on the
nova scotian coast
is prone to the development of sinkholes
with very similar properties to those
described in the original money pit
now i know what you're thinking what
about those oak platforms and the
cryptographic stones that were found in
the money pit and all the other stuff
which if you've been watching the tv
series i'm sure you're aware of
you certainly wouldn't find anything
like that in a sinkhole
and that's a very good point the trouble
is most of those key pieces of evidence
apart from recent fines all seem to have
inconveniently disappeared
at least a hundred years ago
and until someone tracks them down
they're just another part of the oak
island legend i mentioned earlier that
there have been some interesting
archaeological finds on oak island and
that's absolutely true
but that certainly doesn't prove the
existence of buried treasure
if you dig enough holes anywhere where
humans have lived for any length of time
you're going to find an artifact or two
sooner or later we've been leaving our
crap lying around for millennia after
all combine all of this reasonable doubt
with the fact that dozens of expeditions
over more than two centuries have tried
and failed to retrieve the treasure of
oak island
and well
it just doesn't look great does it don't
get me wrong it's certainly possible
that there's treasure down there
it's possible that there's treasure
pretty much everywhere
but
if i were a betting man
i know where i'd be putting my money at
this point that might seem like a kind
of disappointing end to this strange
tale but in my book the story is
actually all that more interesting if
there isn't any treasure
i mean just think about it if there was
never any buried treasure on oak island
that means that thousands of people
including at least two hollywood greats
and one u.s president have spent an
unfathomable amount of time and money
digging holes in the mud on a random
island in the middle of nowhere for
basically no reason whatsoever
and if that's the case then the oak
island mystery isn't the longest running
treasure hunt in the world
it's the greatest practical joke in
history
[Music]
thanks for watching